the specials i think yeah yeah
definitely the longest so far the lead
time for the specials is just like so
[ __ ] long that sometimes you forget
that they're coming out yeah you're like
what did was this a good special i can't
remember like i remember
seeing the first draft of the drifting
special on the cycling special i
remember my first thought was i can't
believe i had wasted all this time to
like record this [ __ ]
like by the time this episode comes out
the cooking special's probably out right
yeah yeah yeah i mean i guess we can
talk about that yeah just like that oh
my god that first draft took like how
long
that's just because i think you know it
was one of those situations where trash
taste takes priority yeah and because
we're not you know because we know
people are willing to wait we do it does
take a while because it's not
prioritized at all like we don't say and
i guess we we do want it to be like the
best [ __ ] quality yeah yeah we don't
mind making weight because you know
so much work goes into the shoot
it's the one thing i don't want to
compromise on in terms of like quality
yeah um can we talk about the kendo
special
i guess sure okay so so yeah so
we released a picture of us filming a
kendo special and uh god
and like that was like months and months
and months ago and a lot of viewers may
have just like forgotten about it but i
know i see some reddit posts every now
and again bringing that special up like
when when's the kendo special coming
when is it coming uh we actually
scrapped the special because we
we filmed for an entire day um we got
all the source footage and then mood on
edited a first draft and we thought it
was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] and
we thought like there's only like uh
there's only so much we can save through
editing and voiceover because the source
footage unfortunately just wasn't there
so we had to make the decision to just
do we try and
maybe frame this maybe release this as a
mini special or maybe like something
something different maybe it goes in the
after dark channel but we eventually
came to the decision that uh we spent an
entire day he's filming we hired like
three cameramen four maybe four and
ashley as a sound guy we hired the kendo
people um and we uh scrapped it we just
we just like i think like in general it
there was like self room for salvation
but i don't think it would have i think
we can all agree it wouldn't have been
up to the standard of where we see trash
taste that could have been like it could
have yeah it could have been like a
decent just like you know vlog style
video or anything like that yeah but
like yeah as a as a special and
especially after the cycling special
like yeah we you know we didn't we
wanted to make something that was at
that level of quality or above yeah and
kendo special no matter how much we
could do no matter how much mudan could
do yeah just would not get to that stand
itself yeah exactly yeah and uh i mean
that doesn't mean we're not going to do
a kendall special part of the reason we
decided to scrap it was because we saw
potential to
make it right and make it make it make
it learn a lot on that show we did learn
a lot i mean you you don't learn without
failing right exactly and you know it
[ __ ] it [ __ ] hurt because i
remember i remember we were discussing
what to do with this special for so
[ __ ] long i was like do we release it
did we try and do something without do
something with it and it was just on the
back burner for like months and months
and then it was a hard decision but i
feel like it's moments like this where
you really really [ __ ] learn
something and part of the reason i think
the cooking special is going to be good
was because we took so many of the
lessons that we learned from this failed
special um which we may reboot to a
proper special that meets our standard
but we we took so much from this one
experience which was a very expensive
you know mistake you know it was it
wasn't expensive experience but uh
that's that's kind of like that's kind
of like the quality the bar of quality
we want to set yeah at least for our
specials a [ __ ] a [ __ ] podcast we
can just argue about bone on chicken or
[ __ ] whatever shitty food take we get
for like a millionth time and that's
fine you know yeah but the special is
like something we really want to make
sure we like [ __ ] hit the nail yeah
but uh yeah i mean hopefully hopefully i
mean the cooking space will be out by
the time this episode comes out so uh
it's the previous it's the episode
before this one oh it's the episode
before this one
yeah
i'm sorry 81 special cooking special
yeah by the time you guys have seen this
you can see the cooking special from
last week but uh we don't know as of us
recording right now
uh so yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed it
you got robbed robbed
[ __ ] no you didn't
you were never close to winning connor
you're never close you're never going to
win
you're never
was an impartial judge she played her
role perfectly
she was the chaotic evil that we needed
in that video
impartial judge bro
dude dude it's caused my sweat just you
know it tasted better obviously
obviously that was the reason yeah this
you're missing this if you haven't
watched it go wash the trash taste go
watch the trash taste cooking special we
did put a lot of work into it yeah but
uh i think like the aim for 2022 for us
is to like maybe get
a couple more specials out
that'd be nice i mean
without without compensating quality
right yeah yeah i mean i mean we've got
a few ideas which i think are going to
be really really good um they're going
to be big um as well so don't worry
about yeah it's it's all bad we did we
could have done more yeah
because i could have we could have we
could have but it would have been like
really difficult in the year that we had
yeah especially with the restrictions it
was it was very difficult but part part
of part of the reason was every time we
come up with a special idea we just like
go to like mailing or geeks plus and be
like oh can we can we can we get
approval for this place and they'd be
like nope everything's on the lock down
right now pretty much and that would
just delay things for another few months
and then the next few months and then
that just like that was just the first
three quarters of the year basically and
then scrapping the ones really set us
back on the schedule yeah it's a bit
unfortunate really so you could have had
two specials this year but we scrapped
one special ideally we want what three a
year is that the soft thing that we you
set three or two i'd like at least two i
think three i don't i don't want to like
push too fast as someone who just cut
back to uh two uploads a month that's
because three was two months less
i must say two a year let's promise two
at least but let's check for three let's
try four we'll try for three because
some of the ideas we have are going to
take months of [ __ ] planning yeah
three maybe i like i would like to i'm
the optimistic side of me says three of
you yeah but the realistic side of me
says two of you yeah
we we got our streams we got our streams
we're focusing on as well
when i started anime in minutes and i
promised one a month and uh look look
how look how that turned out well that's
just clown that's clown buffoon right
there
you can't bro how are you gonna schedule
voice acting sessions bro
i thought i had min maxed it and then i
realized that i couldn't get it to the
it actually wasn't the uh voice acting
side it was just the scripting side
where i couldn't get it to
the
quality that i wanted for every series i
think it's also just gonna be hard to do
three year not only because of you know
like the after dark stuff we're doing as
well but also just the fact that i think
like on all of our main channels we're
just gonna like 20 22 is just like
another stepping quality up yeah and
just time taken and so it's like
yeah we need all the help we can
basically
i would like to like just for myself i
would like to get at least two out yeah
i think i think that's a good i mean i
mean we we could have easily done it
last year yeah and we did film two last
years we did do last two so if if one
wasn't if one wasn't a learning
experience we would we would have had to
so that i think that we didn't [ __ ] up
you'd have to yeah
yeah unfortunate circumstances made us
[ __ ] up yeah you know it's whatever but
speaking of something that is uh not
going to be a special just yet
we almost died
wow
call back
again whoa connor needs to pee what what
what is [ __ ]
keep this in moon on this is rare
evidence of connor asking for a toilet
break before me or
before me or joey have even asked i've
never asked to pee before you know i'll
i'll take this i'll take this rare
opportunity to also yeah i might as well